the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
this is 1473 with challenge challenges
of world poverty
i'ma begin Banerjee I'm going to be
lecturing on and off more in tandem with
Esther Duflo
you hear me at the back I can't figure
the acoustics you hear me well okay so I
I guess just to give a short description
of what this class is so this is a class
which is meant to introduce you to
conversations very broad conversations
about the questions relating to world
poverty so it's it's not a technical
class it's not a class that's meant to
teach you very sharp analytical tools
it's a car class that's meant to teach
you how to participate in the great
debates of the world and so to get you
part involved with the great debates of
the world it's very much in that sense
the spirit of the class is is quite
different from many other MIT classes
and that's deliberate because I think
it's it's wonderful that there we have a
lot of technical classes at MIT but it's
also very useful to occasionally step
back and think of what this means for
for the for the big picture and for how
we think about living in the world so
this this is very much a class of that
kind it's based very specifically on
this book which the book is called poor
economics
that's a depending on who you ask a good
or bad pun it's it's a play on the sort
of the idea of a different way of
thinking about economics and be on the
idea that this is economics relevant to
poverty so it's a play on that it's a
book that we just finished it hasn't
been published so you'll be literally
the first people other than our close
friends who will who have
we'll get a chance to read it and the
Laura can you make sure that everybody
has these was someone somebody make sure
this is this is the process we just have
to manage so the the goal of this book
is to sort of the ballroom book was
written to can integrate a whole bunch
of stuff that we've been working on for
20 years nearly and into a common
narrative on how to think about poverty
so the book is a and book is has a bunch
of chapters each chapter and we're going
to be basically following the book so
the book is not available in the market
you'll all be able to buy a copy of the
kind of D the manuscript version of it
now and we're going to follow the book
chapter by chapter forward from
beginning to end so that's sort of this
is a class as I said it's a class that's
not based on technical material it's not
a list you will not have problem sets on
the other hand we expect you to read
what what's in the in our book and
what's in this else that's in the
syllabus quite carefully we're going to
have pop quizzes one of the ways in
which this class will be graded is with
pop quizzes that will be you know kind
of randomly on random dates and on the
topic of the week so you we expect you
to have read stuff that's one second
thing that is different about this class
is there's a class that's as I said it's
meant to kind of get you involved in
big-picture thinking
but that doesn't mean that it's a class
that doesn't so expect you to know the
details of what water was being talked
about in fact the running theme of this
classes that you can't fix the problems
the world unless you pay attention to
the details so what we're going to ask
you to do is as part of the requirement
for the class is to write at least five
essays short as a very short essays
which will be graded and which will be
on specific aspects of the topics
covered in class so you you'll have to
write we're going to the way we're going
to do the grading is that there will be
you can write up to 12 SS the 12
basically 12 topics you could write 12
SS we're going to give you a grades for
the best 5 and so if you feel like
writing one every week you can write one
if you feel like writing just 5 that's
good too you're going to get graded on
the the best 5 you have to write one
longer essay which will at some point in
the semester and there will be a final
exam so it's a it's as I said it's
different from many MIT classes more if
different from any other MIT class I've
ever taught in that it's not based on
problem sets it's based on these essays
MIT economics class I don't know what
literature classes well MIT economics
classes typically a problem set this is
going to have essays it's going to focus
on being able to articulate coherent
interesting thoughts about the problems
of poverty so it's it is very much about
these essays are going to be important
and and reading and writing will be
important so we want you to and we what
goes with that naturally is discussions
will be important we want we're going to
have classes where there'll be a lot of
discussion that's why we want you to
have read the read the pieces we are not
going to go line by line through those
pieces we want
have a combination of some lecturing and
a lot of discussion the one of the
things that that where there becomes
relevant is that we're going to have
we're going to have this class is being
videotaped if you notice there's a
camera up there clasping of be
videotaped but the only part of the
videotape that will be used will be
publicly available will be the lecture
part of it the rest of it will be the
discussions will be will not be on or on
the OCW website so there will not be
they'll eventually be experts so you
should not feel feel uncomfortable over
speaking out we want you to be involved
in the discussion passionate in the
discussion argue with each other
argue with us so you should feel
comfortable it shouldn't it's the the
it's not that you are being put on
camera and everything you ever said that
was potentially maybe incorrect or is
going to be recorded for all history and
made available on the web so we're going
to be very careful in only keeping the
lecture so it's a very much a class that
needs the discussion it won't be fun if
if there isn't a lot of discussion and
having taught this before I would say
the converse is also true when there's a
lot of discussion it's a lot of fun
because the issues are fundamental at
some level very live issues and it's
things where you have thought about them
many of them maybe this will change the
way you think about it but it's it is
these are things that are fairly
elemental and immediate and I think you
will you will if you get into the spirit
of it and you'll enjoy it so I think
that's by way of background if you have
a question right now
okay so then so when we plan to start
this is by you you you notice to be
given one randomly picked sheet each the
sheet comes with a little form to fill
out you can read the sheet and think
about what what your reaction will will
be remember that this is for real so you
will get some ten of you will get the
money so it's real money that you are
assigning to one of these tutor you or
you have choice between giving the money
to save save the children or not giving
it and we don't expect which there's no
obligation you so the way it's going to
work is you're going to select how much
you were to give then we will have a
lottery and you will get some of some
ten of you will win the money and when
you win the money that money will be
deducted from the amount you have
proposed and the rest you will go to you
okay is that clear how that works some
of you will go get nothing you know just
hypothetically written down an amount of
money
others will actually get that money ten
dollars and out of that you would have
said I want to give these people 50
cents and then 50 cents will be deducted
and you get a $9.50 sort of given to you
so that's that's that's the plan plan
for this experiment so we'll find out
what the results are and
and what we'll discuss what they mean in
a little bit in the meanwhile I'm going
to play I'm gonna play two videos and
we'll play two videos which are two
which represent two very specific and
very well known points of view on what
to do about world poverty the first one
is is features somebody who was my one
who taught me when I was a graduate
student at Harvard jeffrey sachs and
angelina jolie angelina jolie and
jeffrey sachs go to africa and they
discover poverty or I know our Angelina
discovers poverty and the Jeff's
tutelage and and then they have they
very clearly articulate a theory of
poverty and what to do about it
etc and then from so Jeff Jeff is now at
Columbia University in New York his arch
enemy is a man called Bill easterly who
is a professor at NYU so the next video
is just we go south from Columbia to NYU
and we play mr. easterlies video next so
what you were to do is we're going to
just sit and watch some videos these
this is not an exam exemplar of the the
kind of material you will have to deal
with this is a there will be much denser
material and this this is this is you
know a little fluffier than most things
you're going to have to
but it's it's I think they are
interesting and they take very
well-defined positions so we is listen
to them while thinking of what the
position is that these people are taking
and why those positions you know what is
the underlying theory of poverty the
response to it all of those are being
articulated through this process and and
you should kind of source come and then
will once once it ends we're going to
actually spend a little bit of time
discussing what we learn from the video
so so think of questions or comments
you're going to make
I want this to sink in for a minute
and in the meanwhile I'll kill it let me
talk about what we just we just compiled
the results let's start with those
results we'll come back to will they
will spend the rest of the time talking
about this so the results suggest either
that week that many experiments that
other people have done we're wrong or
that we didn't do it right or more
likely you guys are more generous than
the rest of the world so this is an
experiment that's been done many times
and the experiment would you let me
explain there what the experiment is an
experiment typically the way it's done
it's very different here because we
couldn't figure I mean we have we wanted
to do it in class and do it for real so
that made it a little so instead of
giving people ten dollars the way it's
usually done is that somebody kind of
walks through the most famous version of
this was done at the at the University
of Pennsylvania somebody walked through
the cafeteria distributing five dollars
to people just without much explanation
really and then about a few minutes
later somebody came up and handed each
of these people they're all randomly
chosen one or the other of these letters
there were actually two different
letters I you you none of you should
have seen both but I don't know if you
have they're basically both both the
letters are telling a story of you know
some some reason to help
so the first there's one letter which is
a letter that tells us sort of a very
general story
the story is about you know here are
many problems in the world
B there is whatever children children
are let me just read out the for those
of you yeah so the nine million children
die before their fifth birthday actually
I think I have them on the slide let me
just see if I I do in which case I'll be
easier no okay
nine million children die before the
fifth birthday a woman the probability
that a woman in sub-saharan Africa will
die before in childbirth is 1 in 30 if
you did the same number for the rich
countries is one in 5,600 so in the
trade 25 countries in the world most of
them in sub-sahara Africa where the life
expectancy at birth is less than 55
years and so on and so one of these
letters which half of you read was a
kind of catalogue of these problems and
then asks and then asks the you to
decide how much money you want to give
to Save the Children which is a
well-known organization we try to solve
this problems that's the rest of you got
a letter which described the life of one
individual child called rakia and that
child is you know has has a whole range
of problems and then again asks you to
give money towards helping a child let's
say rakia herself was child like her now
what you guess about which in in the
point of this experiment was that one of
these letters
is a lot more money than the other and
what would your guess be personal story
personal story typically raised about
twice as much more than twice as much as
the other one
now that turned out to be not true in
this room it raised exactly the same
amount so it raised the personal story
raised eight eight dollars and 63 cents
and the other story raised seven dollars
and ninety-six cents which are
statistically and indistinguishable so
the experiment basically failed here now
why it failed
I guess we'll come back to this question
actually maybe if you have time let me
but I think that my guess is that you
you just you selected in being in this
classroom and therefore you're more
generous but maybe we could think of
other reasons why but but the point of
the experiment hadn't succeeded or the
point of way people have usually
interpreted it so the average person
seems to react in this very different
why do you think we will react very
differently but all of you had the same
you seem to agree on the answer
basically out of five dollars you give
two dollars and sixty cents to rock here
one dollar and thirty cents to the
general problem or something like that
and when you tell people that you know
you give more to rakia then it goes down
to one dollar and thirty cents for both
so that's that that that that sort of I
think brings out very nicely one of the
key issues here which is that I think
once you start thinking about once you
made to think that the Rokia problem is
somehow an exemplar of a general problem
you start now thinking it's it's like
the general problem and then we can't
solve it and then it's like people step
back so I think I think this is sort of
this scale effect this idea that well
it's a big problem we're scared and we
don't want to deal with it is sort of
one of the
one of the stuff I mean one of the
starting points of where we want to
start from and and maybe get away from
is this idea that you know that this
this is an enormous problem and
therefore we can't do anything about it
now that so if you think of one goal we
want to have in this class is in a sense
to move exactly away from that feeling
in other words we what we want to do is
to move away from thinking about you
know one day the cha we think of the
challenges being one day we're going to
take a you know a big shovel and we're
going to throw all poverty out that's
not that's now not how anything ever
happens and so there's no reason to
think of it that way it's and you
clearly don't but the rest of the world
does I mean so there is a sense in which
do what we want to do in this class is
to think of the problem of poverty as up
as a set of specific efforts that if we
do it right we will solve them and if
you don't do it right well we will we go
make things worse so we want to turn it
into a set of specific challenges maybe
we can solve those challenges but at
least let's first move away from
thinking of it as being this one grand
problem to thinking about as as a
hundred individual problems each of
which with a potential solution okay so
that's sort of where we want to get to
at the end of this semester we won't
have an answer to how do you solve world
poverty I can guarantee you that what we
might get is a sense that these are
actually individual problems that we can
a set of individual problems we can
start thinking about as solvable
you know the solvable things that we can
stop apply our minds to and some of them
will have answers to some of them will
just be throw throw them out as
challenges and
see what happens at the end okay so
that's where we want to get you want to
turn this grand problem into a set of
specific individual problems that sort
of and so the whole semester will be in
thinking about specific issues like the
ones that Sachs brought up well and the
ones that easterly brought up and try to
turn them into problems that we can have
have some kind of a leverage over the
minister so it's some level this is
stuff that's and some of this just just
just to go back to the now to the to the
video videos sex does a very good job of
kind of posing the problem I think he I
think the I mean easterly I think won't
disagree on that I think if you if you
think about what the problem is
well many ways to say it one way to say
this just that people are extremely poor
I mean just a measure of poverty is is
in some ways itself kind of a useful way
to think about just to take just a scale
of it the scale of it is you think think
about those numbers the poverty line
turns out that mostly by some peculiar
accident India's both the country which
has the maximum number of poor people in
the world and it's the country which has
if you take the poverty line in India do
you know what the poverty line is who
knows what a poverty line is yeah
right it's just a way to define for how
do you say somebody's poor you say in
the u.s. you say somebody is poor if
they have $14 if their consumption is
less than $14 per head per day that mean
that includes lots of stuff it includes
you know housing and all those things so
it's not $14 it's not $14 in in Big Macs
it's $14 in clothes and everything but
it's so that's how you define poor in
the u.s. for the rest of the world the
way it's typically people use is a
dollar a day a dollar a day is roughly
it turns out the equivalent of the
poverty line of India or equivalently
the average of the poverty lines for the
50 countries where the most of the poor
lives so you take the 50 countries in
where all the poor people live take the
average of the poverty lines and say
that you know the poverty lines vary
across countries because countries some
countries think that you know $14 is the
bare minimum that you need to live other
countries have a more you know even more
accepting of misery and said that even
if you have $1 that's fine but if you're
less than $1 you're poor so it turns out
that the effective definition that a lot
of people use is is a dollar a day on 99
cents a day this this number is now used
a lot which is called dollar a day
poverty if you look at the set of people
who are who are who live under a dollar
a day 865 million people this is sort of
Jeff Sachs is 850 million people live
under a dollar a day so that's that's
that sort of just to get a scale of how
many poor people are there in the world
well if you define it to be a dollar a
day which is 114 to what it is in the US
you still get end up with about a
billion people so that's sort of a one
way to think about how big the problem
is
it also is a way to think about how sort
of surprising the problem is I mean you
would think that I mean that says that
per capita average GDP per capita in the
u.s. is $47,000 that's like $50,000
$50,000 divided by 365 so that's like
mmm how much is that it's 50,000 divided
by 500 is a hundred right so a hundred
people or 150 people in the in the rest
of the world live on less than the
average income of one person average
person in the u.s. so that's one way to
scale the problem is to say that the
average person in the u.s. lives 150
times better than the average person in
the average poor person in the world and
that's sort of that's a minimum because
you know these people are not at the
poverty line they're below the poverty
line so so just to set a get a sense of
these magnitudes what's enormous ly what
in a sense is surprising about this is
that you know there is like somehow that
the gap is so huge it's like it's not
that there is a gap of you know 10
percent or 15 percent or 50 percent or
200% it's a gap of fifteen hundred and
fifty times or something like that
so we're just talking of the order of
magnitude is just stunning here and
somehow that would seem like it's easy
then it should be easy to fix I mean if
there's such big gaps then isn't a
little bit of aid from the US couldn't
would it make huge difference in this
countries and so it shouldn't be easy to
make this country richer and somehow
that's
this conversation is stuck so if you
think of where this conversation is
coming out of it's coming out of a
feeling well we are so rich and these
people are so poor why can't we do
something about it
now what so now let's go
maybe we talked about this so let's now
go back to the video with that sort of
background I'm going to say one last
thing and I just want you to look at
this one picture just as a last parting
thought so this is what he still is
this is easterlies famous picture he
chose that the picture shows the blue
bars are aid it keeps going up and down
but it's basically going up up over time
and and that's and you see that you know
despite the fact that the aid is sort of
going up and the cumulative of all this
when he says that that's that's how much
it has gone in the cumulative all this
is the total aid that's gone in you can
see that the GDP per capita seems
basically flat so it is going in is
being pushed in and in and in and in and
you see this blue East blue blue bar is
adding up to the next one now and this
is sort of his reading of history now
the thing that one of the things we're
going to worry about here is what we're
going to call the counterfactual so what
I think easterly has in mind is that
without the a so the question is what
would have happened without the aid
right and I think the first problem in
reading any of this data is and this is
a key idea so I want you to I want to
stop on this is figuring out what would
have happened if we hadn't given the aid
so one possibility is that that yellow
line is what would have happened
that's kind of that's the without aid
the yellow line would have happened with
aid you got the red line and the red
line is better than the yellow line the
alternative which easterly seems to
assert is that the green line is what
would have happened absent the aid and
that the difference between the two the
negative difference is is what is the
consequence of it so in some sense this
is the so this is sort of where now the
problem is that this now once you get to
this point to be honest doesn't we have
nothing to say because we don't know
what happened absent aid right we have
we've only one history to look at and we
look at this one history this history
could be anything you want so in other
words I'll disappoint you from the
beginning and tell you that this is a
question we'll never know the answer to
in fact we know that we don't never know
whether historically Aid was a mistake
or not is not one of the questions we'll
answer to calibrate expectations for
this class what we will try to answer is
suppose you had to give aid how would
you give it that's a question that we
can answer and that there all the issues
you raised are important the issues of
whether people will take up things you
give them is there a demand for the bed
nets that's a very key issue is it the
case that when we try to give it to them
you know the mechanism through which we
deliver the aid let's say the bed nets
the government government has to give
them out for free and all the privates
market shut down or that's as you raised
that's another concern a third concern
will be about where the local volunteers
can deliver bed nets do we need markets
after a fourth concern will be is it is
it the case that when when we start
delivering badness to local volunteers
local volunteers become too powerful
politically and they exploit their
political power for other purposes each
of these concerns that I think you
raised implicit
will become a central concern in
thinking about this question so we're
going to think about questions not on
the kind of this kind because this
question has no answer
alas we'd love to know the answer to
this question but I don't I don't think
anybody can the kind of question we will
be able to answer are is it that if you
had to give out aid what's the best way
to do it so that's the kind of question
we try to answer and we'll spend the
whole semester in a sense on that
question so hope to see you next next
lecture